[音楽]
me
人は
なぜ悩むでしょうか
そそことについてずっと考え続けてきました
今僕の結論としてはヒ素は体から内部
母ではなくて頭の世界
になったらその絵悩みは消えていくそういうような経験をみなさんに共有したいと思い
ます
僕て僕は両親が台湾出身で京都で生まれ育ちました
何不自由なく何の疑問もなく日本人として育ってきたんですけれども
あると聞い
小3ぐらいの時ですね
正月休みを掛けた時に
クラスのみんなが
集まって話をしている
次におじいちゃまとかおかあちゃまの家に行ってお雑煮を食べても家が丸かったのとか
そのうちはもちろん資格だったよという風に言うんですね
ちょっと待ってよっ
家
で食べてことないんだけど
ももちってなんですよお雑煮に入ってるものなんだよ
あれ
ずっと日本人やと思って過ごしてきたけれども日本人じゃないのかな
でも
例えば台湾に行って様神の親戚や家族友達に会って
台湾語をしゃべるわけでもない中国をしゃべるわけでもない中で俺自分は
回1チンでもないのかな
自分は日本人なのか台湾人なのかという母にすごく
苦しめられていました
[音楽]
今日本で
仕事をしてそしてそれを台湾でも仕事をするようになると
あ自分は日本人でもあり台湾地でもあるということにすごく大きな価値があるという
ことに気づきました
僕はの台湾で公演をするときに必ず
お玉眞柴第1弾は4月政治チューリップん
お野菜今回市諏訪という風に言うんですけどこれは私のお父さんお母さんは台湾人です
台湾語ちょっと喋れますでも日本で生まれました
これを一言を言うだけでさすごく笑ってくれて
やりやすくなんですねー
日本人であり台湾人であるというその子のか違う
自分にはあるんだということにすごく救われましたん
日本人なのか台湾人なのかというふうな川で悩み苦しみそして日本人と台湾人とと言う
との世界に救われたんですね
僕は2年前まで医学生として逆を勉強してたんですけれども
初めて病院に医学生として勉強始め時に自分は患者さんの立場で見たらいいのかそれと
も
医師の立場で見たらいいのかその母になりました
医師の立場としてみるにはあまりにも経験や知識が足りない
でも
患者さんの立場に見るにしても別にその病気を自分が経験してるわけでもないしその
家族でもない
どこに自分の価値があるんだなっ
ことになりました
それが
ちょっと待てよと患者さんの立場を持っているし
医師の立場持っているその視点をどちらも持っているということな価値が学生にあると
いうことを受けてきた
例えば患者さんには
医師には言えないけれども回ってくる医学生学生さんぐらいの言えるみたいことがある
んです
逆もまた然りで医師の方も患者さんには直接的すぎて言えないけれども
医学生に教えられる未来パートナー
その両方の立場と視点と考えを用いることが学生の大きな価値なっていただきつきまし
た
患者と医師とどちらの視点を持てばいいのかということから患者と
イシュトどちらの視点もモテるという医学生の価値に気付いたんですよ
また今
僕は名古屋のある病院で医師として働いていますけど
どういう医療やるかそれをどうやるかっていうことに関してごを決めていくもの
でしょうか
医療の意思決定とはどういうふうにされていくのもいいましょうか
患者さんが決めるのか医師が決めるのかっていうような
新がいっぱいあります
例えば
入団の
若いお母さん10歳ぐらいの子供がいる人
by というと
医師がこの人に対して手術をするか薬をするかということに
対しては
例えばこの元がどれぐらい進行しているか店員はあるか他の症状はないか
そういった客観的なものをにベースに考えですね
でも一方でじゃあ患者さんに聞いてみると
そういった客観的なものではなくてむしろ主観的なもの
自分がもし手術を受けておっぱいがなくなったら
初めて自分の子供息子をお風呂言えるときに自分のないよっぱいについてどう説明し
たらいいですか
ここから入るんです
医師は
客観的なものから考えるかもしれませんでも主観的なものを患者さんをより大事に
するっていう中で
患者さんが決めるのか良い子が決めるのかということがすごく問題になります
そこを患者さんと医師とかと一緒に決めることができるのかということを僕らは考えて
いけないと思います
それは何をやるか何をやらないかではなくてそれはなぜやるかそしてなぜやらないかと
いうことをお互いに共有しながら話し合って決めていくことです
その結論が手術になるか
薬になるかが大事なことではありませんその決めていく過程を患者さんと医師が一緒に
共有していくということに意味があるんです
だから患者さんか石川ではなくて患者さんと医師とが
医療どういう医療を受けるかというのを決めてくるそういう必要が僕があると思います
また
これからの世代を生きる僕たちは
どんな仕事に就いて言っても ai というものについて
無関係ではいられないと思います
いろんな新聞やニュース騎乗をひもとけば
ai が人の仕事を奪う人は ai よっておくがある
医師もそうです ai
は一種の仕事を奪っていくだろう医師は ai に代替される
そういう話ばっかりずいわゆる ai 回しかの話がいっぱいあると思います
いいブラー人の家と呼ばれる
ジェリーヒントン教授はですね2016年
ニューヨーカーという雑誌のコラムに
画像をベースにして
判断する放射線科医という意志は頬の育成をやめるべきだというふうに入ってるんです
ね
なぜなら ai がすべてを代替できるかするという風に言っています
まさに彼も
ai 開始加藤
有用な世界観定期ていたのかなと思います
ただ実は
その1年後に
ゼリーヒント教授は同じニューヨークは雑誌にコラムをしています
一種の役割は進化するんだと
あんなんなる画像を見る人からそれ以上のものに進化していくという風に
僕たちは考えないといけないのは a 4位回しか
a 良いか1かではなくて
ai 砥石とどういうふうに伝えで公ができるか ai と人をどうやって繋いで新た
な価値を生んでいくか
それを僕たちは考えないといけないと言う
また
新しいお札の肖像画になる
渋沢 h さんという人がですね
数百社自分の自分とか会社を作るその支援をする中で
会社経営とは何かというような本を書いています
当タイトルが論語カストロバーンではなくて論語と算盤だなんですけれども
会社経営とは
そろばんをはじきながら利益を追求していかないといけない
だから利益を追求していかないと会社作れてしまう
一方で論語のような哲学や道徳や価値観に基づいたものに
ベースに
この会社がどういう社会的な価値を生み出そうかどういう役割を担うかということを
考えないと存在水域がないといったようです
論語かそろばんではなくて論語と算盤であるということが
大事です
黒子にある良型のひゃんぺーんですね
クラウドファンディングといういろんな人からお金を集めて
参加啓発キャンペーンをやるということだったんですけれどもお金を逆型の
キャンペーンでお金はあってるとは何もとやっ
お前お金のためにやってるのかように言われたことがあります
そうやって僕たちはもしかしたら
お金のためか人のためが社会のためかってどれか死か
実現できないと思ってるんじゃないでしょうか
生きていくためにはお金が必要ですでも一方でそれを何のために使うのかということも
同時に考える
論語カーそろばんではなくて low モードそろばんということを僕たちは実践して
いかないといけないなと思います
ここ数年
5か今26歳なんですけれども
同世代の
何かがいい
自らこの超
いたしました
彼のことを思うと
生きるか死ぬかという
母人
すごく苛まれて
追い詰められて追い立てられたんじゃないかなというふうに思います
シェイクスピアの
有名な言葉でもう
生きるか死ぬかそれが問題だというふうな場がありますが
生きるか死ぬか
それが本当に問題なんでしょうか
僕は
生きるということと死ぬということが共にあるあり方はあるんじゃないかと思います
生きづらさを抱えてあるところでは生きていけない苦しい辛い死にたい消えてしまい
たいと思うことあるぞ
ただそれでもそこの自分は死んだとしても
他できている
名前を変えてもいいし
場までの全て捨ててもいいしでもそこでも
どこかできているそういった
生きるということと死ぬということがどちらかではなくてどちらともある
そういうあり方が僕はあるんじゃないかなと言う
なぜ
母が頭になることで新たな価値が生まれるでしょうか
それは
母という世界の中では
交わらず分断されどちらかしか選べなかったものが
頭の中では
お互いがつながり
そしてどちらの性質持ち
そして母となりあったところに新たな価値が新たな分野が新たな概念が生まれからだと
思います
そうした頭には間をつないでその間から新しいものを生み出してそんな力が
あるんだと思います
この間て言うし
僕たちにはすでに備わっていることかじゃないかなと思います
僕たちは
人間です
人でもありますけれども
人間でもあります
人はひとりかもしれない
一人で生きていかなきゃいけばもあるかもしれないけれども
何かと何かと桜
間に立ってそれをつないでいく
そういった存在であるということがこの人間という言葉に
含まれてるんじゃないかと僕はそれを見出したいと思います
そんな何かと何かとの間をつないで
カーの世界ではなくて
頭の世界を共に同じ人間として
共に作っていくそんな仲間になってくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]